becca what is happening how can i help
this morning
all right so uh my husband is in the
navy and he's going on deployment soon
uh we've got a year and a half old
daughter and
um i'm one of those people i'm scared of
the dark i'm scared of everything and so
we were
gonna we have security systems outside
of our house
and then i was thinking about getting a
security camera for inside of our house
so if i'm upstairs and something happens
during the night i can just look at the
camera downstairs right
didn't you watch that movie what was uh
james what was that movie paranormal act
yeah paranormal activity didn't you
watch that no i don't watch
games no cameras in the house you know
what's going to be on those things
all right so you you got cameras outside
everywhere you're terrified
um and now you just want to be totally
terrified all the time 24 7
and be able to see everything all right
so what's your question
so my question is my husband said that
he wanted access to the camera inside
the house while he's on deployment right
okay just to be able to check in on us
to make sure we're okay
but and he was saying for like if he has
a bad day and he's not able to talk to
us
he just wants to look at the camera and
see that we're okay and then kind of go
about his day right
and that's cool but i don't want him to
check in on us and me have a bad day
and like see me frustrated and see me
upset or see me crying or see me
something like that
and then just make his day worse and
because i don't want to feel like i've
failed him
you know i want him to to know that
we're doing okay like i can have my
moments of being sad or whatever but i
just don't want him to check in on us
and see me upset or see me
not doing a good job while he's on
deployment
becca you're awesome guys tell you that
[Laughter]
you're rad dude for real so when you
when you told him that what did he say
i have a feeling i know what he said
because he's awesome too but what did he
say
he said that he understood and that i'm
not going to fail him
that i'm allowed to have bad days but
that just being even if we're upset
like even if he sees us happy and sees
us playing then that'll give him
what he needs to get through the day or
even if he just sees me sitting on the
couch by the fireplace reading a book
like
that's what he would need to get through
the day and that's cool like i'm happy
that
i hope we have good days right like
that's what i'm hoping for but i'm just
scared if he looks at it
twice and both times i'm having a hard
time
i just i don't want it to be more
trouble than it's worth i just don't
want to make it worse
so here's what you got back of it's
pretty cool
you have a husband that doesn't like
doesn't love
that isn't in love with a fantasy or a
mirage
he's in love with an entire person
he's in love with the good stuff the bad
stuff
the weird hair you have on your back the
yeah
the the weird whatever
the you look different than when you
start dating the
time you get the zit he's in love with
all of you
and when he's overseas
yes it would be cool to just have
glamour shots
done up all day 24 7 so when he happens
to beam in
from his bunk and his little tablet and
he can look in
as just a seeing eye on the people that
he loves the most in the whole wide
world the reason he's doing all this
this extraordinary service yeah it'd be
cool to be all glammed up and
but man he's a guy that also wants to
see his wife have tears
that's going to tell him that you miss
him
that's going to tell him that you matter
to him
yeah and he loves all of you
and so here's the thing i think house
cameras are crazy
i don't have any house cameras um
i may get them someday um i like to live
in the illusion that i don't want to
know
if my house is being stormed by
stormtroopers i just prefer to just go
quietly in the night and so be it
i super prefer you gotta watch
paranormal activity dude that movie's a
trip
so i super prefer not looking over at my
whatever camera and seeing some
demon staring at me that would suck um
but if you
i'm a fighter you're a what i'm a
fighter
i am too pissed already i'm a fighter oh
trust me dude we're armed to the gills
i just don't want to see you coming man
so we're yeah we're good
um but yeah it's not an open invitation
i just i'm also weird i don't want
people hacking into my house cameras and
all that kind of stuff
but here's the deal if you and your
husband are camera people
and he has said i love you and i love
all of you and i want to check in
and he gives you peace then be fully
human and fully present
and i can imagine a scenario where that
kind of technology allows you
and your kids to leave notes and
pictures
it also allows him to see you crying and
being fully a person
and it allows him to see you laughing
you can set up dates where you
dance in the living room uh that sounded
super weird not that kind of dance but
like
a slow dance right um and you can have
imaginary
dance dates whatever dude i'm getting
creepy now but whatever that's going to
be
um i could see them in the booth it's
just getting down a dark road here i
wasn't trying to be that kind of dancing
he's a military guy i want him to bomb
my house or something but
um and here's the deal how many cameras
i'm not going to see him coming if he
gets mad at me but
um dude i think it's a beautiful thing
and i think the pressure you feel to be
perfect the pressure you feel to
um perpetuate a fantasy for him
is exhausting for you it's
tiring and i think you would give him
some peace of mind if you just wept
openly and you told him i'm gonna really
miss the hell out of you
and i'm proud of you for serving our
country and i'm proud of you for the dad
and husband that you are i'm really
really gonna miss you
and then you all hug regularly i think
that he's gonna
um fall deeper in love with you the more
he gets to know you and if he gets to
see you crying gets to see us
smash in a glass because you're angry or
just see the kitchen or wreck or
whatever you're worried about um
he's going to remember the woman that he
loves becca in seattle washington he's
going to remember you
yeah and so man if y'all are all good
with demons in the house and seeing them
i say camera up family that's going to
be rad
and to the veterans who are deploying
this is the second deployment call we've
taken today
man hug tightly before you go
write letters make sure that you stay
connected and
safe travels and i'm so grateful for
your service i'm grateful for each one
of you who sacrifice yourself and your
families
and comfort to make sure that we all
have
our families together too